hi everyone this is inter from machine
learning group it is my honor to
introduce our work artificial
intelligence for drug discovery
why drug discovery is so important
because it has great business value
it is estimated that by the end of 2025
the global market of drug discovery is
expected to reach 79 billion dollars by
however from discovering a new drug
until the drug is finally approved by
fda it is a very long process
as shown in this picture it takes six
and a half years to design a new drug
and apply some preclinical experiments
clinical experiments means that some
experiments on cells and animals are not
allowed on human after that it takes
about seven years for the clinical
trials which means that we are allowed
to test a new drug on humans but with
limited number
and after that the fda will approve one
of the most successful drug
so we can see that drug discovery is
costly and time consuming
and we want to use artificial
intelligence to help speed up this
process
but as shown here the pre-clinical
trials and the clinic neutrals both
require wet experiments so we focus on
the first part the drug discovery
so there are three things before
pre-clinical the first thing is target
discovery and validation
here a target is some protein or enzymes
or nucleic acids in our body
and its activity can be modified by some
drugs resulting in specific effect
in targeted discovery given a specific
disease we want to try our best to
figure out all possible targets this is
what drug target discovery does
after that we use the target validation
to filter out the wrong targets
the second smart is screening virtual
screening means that we use computer
science program to calculate the binding
affinity of the drug and the target and
we search some library and we want to
find out some possible molecules so that
they can be made drugs in the future
and the main techniques in this part
include docking and molecular dynamics
after that we move to the lead
generation and optimization process this
is because in the previous step we
obtained some molecules but the potency
can be still can still be improved
so we want to improve the molecules from
the previous step and in this stage we
need some techniques including
generating new molecules we need some
techniques about molecule protein
prediction and we need some techniques
on ritual synthesis
we can see that in the about three
stages the molecule modeling is
important task for all the about stacks
so we want to work on this direction
and we propose a new technique bill view
molecule per training for this technique
for these tasks
so before going into the technical
details we should know how to represent
a molecule
so take the artemis artemisinin a very
famous struct as an example here
this is the 2d representation where the
atoms are nose and the edge abounds of a
molecule
after using the depth-first search and
some specific rules like how to break a
ring how to use branch we can convert
the 2d graph into a 1d small string so
this is the basic representations of
molecule
considering that a molecule has two at
least two types of representation
correspondingly there are two types of
the models
so if we regard a molecule as a small
smith as a small stream we can use
transformer to deal with the molecule
and let us use the plutonium as an
example here the input is a smile
sequence we randomly mask some tokens
and we use the transformer to
reconstruct the mask tokens
we can also regard the molecule as a 2d
graph and we can also map some atoms and
let the gene model to recover the masked
atoms
so basically there are two types of
techniques
they are good
but previously the two types of models
are independently used but is that
everything
let's see some cases
here we conduct rich experiments and
show some typical examples here in the
left to in the left part
on the molecule property prediction test
gene succeeds under
on the left two molecules but
transformer fails
for the right to part transformer
succeeds but gene fails
we can see that gene actually favors the
molecules with rich structures for
example more than three rings cognitive
together
but
it does not favor the molecules with
relatively long chain
and in comparison transformer favors
molecules with relatively long trends
but it does not favor the molecule with
rich structure
so
they are complementary to each other and
motivated by this we propose a new model
that leverage the two models together
so this is our solution called do view
molecular pre-training
in our framework an input molecule is
represented by two views
a sequence view which is a smile string
and a graph view which is a 2d graph
representation
we feed the smiles into the transformer
and we feed the
graph into the graph neural network
we first apply the mass language
modeling loss to both transformer and
the gene module
and the transformer module and the gene
module can output the feature for for
the same small molecule because the
features are from the same small
molecule they should be similar in some
latin space
so multiplied by this we use the cosine
similarity to measure to measure their
similarity in some lighting space and
force the two models to minimize the gap
of the two representations
so this is our basic framework
after that we try our model on some
tasks the first task is called molecular
property prediction and the data set is
the molecular net which is the benchmark
data set for molecular property
prediction
we conduct experiments on seven tasks
and we only
we only show three results here the
three tasks are bbbp
which is a task about to predict the
blood brain
a barrier
concentration of drugs and the second
task in clean talks which is related to
predict the toxicity of drugs and the
third task is about the prediction of
the ability of inhibiting hiv
replications
we can see that compared to previous
baseline compared to the transformer
with muscle end model only and compared
to gene with less last masterland
modeling only our method achieve the
best results among all of them
so this shows the effectiveness of our
method
and let's see some cases how our methods
work after using our proposed model we
can see that the model can handle the
molecules with both long
struck with both long chains and
relative reach structures
this shows the effectiveness of our
proposed method
in addition to the prediction tasks we
also apply our model to retrosynthesis
and the task is given a target molecule
we want to use some relatively easily
obtained small molecules to make the
target so this is virtual synthesis
after using our proposed method we can
see that onto benchmark data set our
method further improve the baseline mass
improve the baseline and achieve
state-of-the-art results on these two
tasks
this shows the effectiveness of our
method again
so for future there are many interesting
directions and we'll wait for your
collaborations the first that we will
try more tasks on drug discovery and the
second is that we will design more
advanced models for example how to
design more powerful gene models and how
to use a single model to cover both
transformer and gnn
and third we will try more data
currently we use 100 million data and we
we want to try more in the future
so thanks for your attention and look
forward to your collaborations
next my colleague tong will introduce
his work on drug discovery
thanks insure this is toowong i will
introduce another research project on
drug discovery accurate drug target
interaction prediction for drug
discovery
the war between disease and human beings
has never ended the traditional drug
discovery process is very long from
initial drug discovery to get fda's
approval it usually takes more than 10
years furthermore the drug design cost
is very high which usually spends 1
billion us dollars for nova drug
therefore use machine learning and deep
learning to aid drug discovery also
known as cdd can save lots of time and
money consumption
the cdd can be divided into four steps
first is target identification and
validation
the second one is water screening
and the third one we need to optimize
the properties of drug candidates and
design synthesis passes
all drug candidates should be strictly
evaluated by white experiments and
clinical trials
although cadd can reduce the cost for
drug discovery so crude the accuracy
however don't meet our requirements
since different targets and drugs vary a
lot from each other
so in our research we focus on the
second step drug water screening and
design noaa algorithm to improve the
accuracy and the generalization ability
as shown in the upright figure drug
water screening is to select active drug
candidates from tremendous datasets
which consists of meanings to buildings
of chemical compounds
this task can be divided into two steps
first is the active binding prediction
which selects drug candidates that can
bind to the protein target
second for the active binding drug
candidates we need to determine their
native binding post to the corresponding
target proton
as shown in the lower right figure the
receptor proton is shown as cartoon and
the drug is shown as stick
the region where drug con
to the target protein is called the
binding pocket
our goal
are to predict whether the drug can bend
to the protein
and if so to determine the binding poses
for this task the key challenge is to
how to represent
and distinguish the following three
kinds of interactions
that is
the intramolecular information of the
receptor
the intramolecular interaction of the
ligand
and most importantly the intermolecular
information between the ligand and the
receptor
the most classical approach is molecular
docking
as shown in the red figure docking is a
kind of molecular dynamics that
simulates the movements of the chemical
compounds
with physical force fields
the docking software packages such as
azamina can estimate
whether a ligand combined to our target
receptor and provide the corresponding
binding confirmation
since the targets and the third drugs
vary from each other the accuracy is the
largest challenge
with the development of deep learning
many new algorithms have been proposed
which can be divided into two classes
the first one is to take intramolecular
and intermolecular interactions as a
whole
it uses the whole structure of the
doctor pose as input
and make predictions both for active
binding and pose
one of them kct that uses graph
attention and achieves the best
performance
however this approach cannot distinguish
intermolecular interactions from
intramolecular interactions explicitly
another approach models intramolecular
interactions of ligand and receptor
respectively and the moon is the best
algorithm of this approach
however since it doesn't use a docked
post the intermolecular information
cannot be explicitly modeled
therefore in our study we propose the
intermolecular graph transformer that
use a three-way deep neural network to
model three kinds of interactions
respectively
our igt model can be divided into three
parts first is a feature extraction
module to directly extract
intermolecular and intramolecular
information from novel design item and
bond features
second is a message passing module
and finally the readout module predicts
the final output so in our model the
most important module is the message
passing module that has a survey design
with repeated building blocks to model
interactions within the legend
interactions within the receptor and
most importantly the interactions
between ligand and receptor respectively
we first compare the performance of
active binding production of our model
with other state-of-the-art algorithms
on the most widely used dataset dode
as shown in the figure and the table our
model htt achieves the best performance
on all metrics compared with
state-of-the-art approaches
compared with active binding protection
host prediction is much more useful for
real application in drug discovery it is
worth noticing that since the second
approach doesn't use a doubt pose as
input
it cannot produce the active pose
when evaluated for the active pose
prediction igt achieved the best
performance on all metrics
compared with gta jt
and docking
given the prominent performance of igt
we further use it to identify active
binding drugs against the susquehanna
proteins
as shown in the left figure the
predicted binding pools and the ground
truth are colored green and blue
respectively the binding pocket
of the receptor protein as a color pink
with surface
our predicted binding pose is very close
to the native structure which is
resolved by x3
therefore igt model successfully detects
the near native pose against such co2
furthermore from the middle and the red
panels
that predict when imposed forms similar
interactions that can also be found in
the native structure
given the significant scientific
implications and huge application
potential in healthcare our biomedical
industry our approach can be expected to
provide drug discovery service for
industrial customers
second the massive compounds data and
the huge computational intensive tasks
require either to provide huge storage
on the computational resources
thus
the availability of such technologies in
error will also provide microsoft with
more business opportunities from the
microsoft cloud finally our protocol
predicts active many drugs with property
with proper binding process applied for
regional drug design and contribute to
process medicine
thank you